gotta keep going we're halfway there
we're not even close to halfway there
there's still a lot more controls to go
but you know what guess what I'll tell
you what does keep going me and my crew
here and on-call compliance Solutions
because guess what baby we're back we're
back with another compliance tip of the
week all right and this week we're
talking about cmmccontrol
au.l2-3.3.3.3.3.3.3.3 review and update
logged events
let's talk about it
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand my jokes I
mean all of this cmmc dfarbs and nist
sp80171 compliance stuff on top of an
already colossal workload well I've got
great news for you you found your home
here at on-call compliance Solutions
where we can help you transform into
your company's on-call compliance Hero
Let's jump into it so cmmc control
au.l1-3.3.3.3.3.3.3 review and update
logged events waterlogged events
all right again referring back to the
seam system all right because if you
don't have logged events or you're like
I don't know where I'm logging uh might
be time to call us all right referring
back to seam system what they're really
going for here in this control is a
reference to actually making sure that
someone is really looking at the seam
system okay that means you probably
right someone's got to look at this
thing maybe an I.T director you know
maybe a security officer somebody's got
to be looking at this stuff so like so
many other cyber Security Solutions and
mistakes it's critical that someone
actually is monitoring and reviewing
these systems so when they do alert to
an issue it is promptly looked into and
resolved let's check out what the
assessors are looking for and how to
make them happy on this one now
first of three points determine if a
process for determining when to review
logged events is actually defined uh
again if I was to give an answer this I
would say hey look number one let's come
back to that quarterly risk management
standard operating procedure right let's
look there uh again we're going to
determine some things there in addition
the same solution sends alerts in real
time to system administrators when
information alerts are created which
meet notification thresholds within the
system so again we're going to basically
give a demonstration of the same
solution triggering like a ticket into
our I.T ticketing system something
similar to that
uh second assessment Point determine if
event types being logged are reviewed in
accordance with defined review processes
oh yeah here's that word reviewed
processes that probably means we need a
policy right guys yeah hey it's
implemented via the same solution same
solution sends alerts in real time to
system administrators when information
alerts are created which meet
notification thresholds within the
system all right again a lot of this is
really done totally automated through
the same system but nonetheless you
still have to Define it in your plan all
right third and final assessment point
on this one is determine if event types
being logged are updated based on the
review so again within the quarterly
risk management sop we have standard
operating procedures on how these things
should be updated and again it also has
a requirement that somebody be reviewing
all of those logs and reports and
tickets and things like that to come out
so again you just need to be able it
demonstrate show them hey look yep I'm
looking at the tickets here's the same
ticket and this is our procedure it has
to be in writing in order for us to you
know this is what we follow as a
procedure for doing this
now if you're reading if you're
listening this video and you're like
sweating and you're like oh my God like
what like I don't even have the
beginning of my documentation I don't
even know what a steam system is or if
you just really
frankly want this nightmare of a
compliance standard and cmmc
certification to just go away I have
great news because at on-call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this D fars nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped in their
lap like a seagull on a sunny day we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that is
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and how we can help if
you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
Bible below for links to get help right
now I don't mean like yesterday I mean
like literally you can go on there book
a meeting with us and be on the phone
one of our guys this afternoon
if you love the content we're putting
out here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash that subscribe button to
get the latest compliance content as
soon as our compliance nerds roll it out
until the next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and guess what I'll see you
on the next one
foreign
[Music]